which doesn't belong and why let's start
with cam newton josh allen and kyler
murray they were the top three
quarterbacks in the rushing category for
week one which doesn't belong and why
well i i think i'll go with cam newton
as far as the one that doesn't belong
and why i mean he's the old guy that's
coming off an injury and i didn't expect
him to be like you know a runner in his
first game back basically in you know a
year and a half i know he played two
games early last year but he was nothing
close to 100
so that just was shocking to me let
alone we saw little inklings of this i
knew kyla murray in arizona in the same
place as always what they were gonna do
with him same with josh allen and
buffalo i didn't know what new england
was gonna look like and were they gonna
totally embrace all of the cam newton's
stuff right away in week one and they
did uh i think that's why i'll say i
just
he's 30 he's in the 30s they're not and
i wasn't expecting this much i guess
right away in week one
to me the one that doesn't belong is
much simpler and easier than that we
talk about the importance of keeping
yourself from getting hit if you're a
quarterback yeah kyler murray unlike the
other two has that instinct he combines
speed agility and awareness at a level
that i've never seen it's pretty good
it's good for you to come together right
because remember my mic vic mike you got
to slide i won't slide mark sanchez you
got to slide i can't slide right the guy
who
delivers the blow along the sidelines
like a jimmy garoppolo you know you got
the adrenaline i'm just a competitor i
want to get those yeah right that's
carson wentz i'm you know when i'm out
there on a football field i'm just
trying to get a couple extra hours no
kyler murray
knows when to hit the deck and he's not
too proud to hit the deck he'll hit the
deck anywhere he'll step out of bounds
even if that play after he ran for third
and uh third and 17 scramble for a first
down he's on the sideline he couldn't
try to keep going no i'm just going to
slow down i'm going to look around i'm
going to step out of bounds it's amazing
he is
moving
at normal speed and everyone else is in
slow motion and he has full mastery of
his body in relation to everyone else
and that's what separates him because he
can harness his ability to run and then
immediately turn it off and save himself
for the next play yeah
it is special and you know our man pete
demelitis you know right you know pete
dim a little little little lighter light
of lettuce he put a great stat in here
while you were talking and i think this
is this is via danielle jeremiah of uh
nfl network who's awesome okay but of
the 12 of 13 runs that we you're talking
about on sunday he was only tackled one
time all the other times he slid or ran
out of bounds he was tackled by his
jersey once so there you're you're spot
on plus he's like half the size of josh
allen and cam newton that's why i
thought you were gonna go with this at
first you're gonna be like well i'm
gonna take the the guy that's half the
other two but his awareness his ability
is is off the charts i mean it's fun to
watch so all right good good one where
are we going and it may just be
necessity it's just necessary whatever
it's working you're not a big guy you
can't afford to take a big hit from one
of these guys that's twice your size
yeah all right the next is jimmy
garoppolo carson wentz kirk cousins all
playoff quarterbacks in 2019 who have
started 0-1 which doesn't belong and why
well i i'm gonna look at carson wentz to
be the guy that doesn't belong and why
carson wentz has more on his plate than
the other two i'm just sorry the other
two have weapons and
an offensive scheme around them i don't
know i listen with with kirk cousins i
don't love the kubiak scheme but they
got a really good running back two good
receivers they got you know pretty good
tight end play there's a lot to like
there carson wentz it's just all on him
it's all on his shoulders oh we're up by
17. we can't run the ball and we can't
block on the old line so we're just
gonna keep throwing with you carson
wentz hang in there make plays uh to me
he is
asked to do so much more
uh to deliver for his football team as
compared to the other two who are just
part of a bigger scheme and part of a
bigger you know what do i want to say
just working machine wence is the
machine and they're just trying to find
ways to make him greater all the time or
more ways that you can carry the team
it's just too much at times
yeah i'm gonna say kirk cousins because
we really didn't get a chance to see
what he could do he scored in the 30s
the vikings offense did but the defense
let them down from the get-go from the
opening drive of the game right down the
field and it was aaron rodgers tour to
force and you know at least garoppolo
and wentz had some semblance of a
defense wence had a 17-nothing lead
garoppolo had a 10-nothing lead they at
least had a fair chance to try to win
the game yeah cousins now yeah they did
have no it was actually 7-3 the vikings
led for a little bit it wasn't a
touchdown on that first drive by the
packers but still the wheels were off
before kirk cousins even threw more than
five passes and it was too late for him
to make a difference by then so i didn't
think he'd get he had a fair chance to
try to win the game on sunday because
the defense let them down in a way that
wentz and garoppolo weren't let down by
their defense i got that i get that
you're right they were in the hole early
on i mean even when the game was
somewhat close before that safety by
jair alexander green bay was controlling
the football game i mean they had just
messed it up
to that point but you're right defense
was not good and we'll see we didn't get
a true look i agree with you there next
up a trio of surprise 1-0 teams the
jaguars the washington football team and
the arizona cardinals which doesn't
belong and why well who this is a tough
one here i guess the football team is
the one i'm gonna sit here and say
they don't belong and why just because
i didn't know what to expect
in their football game as far as i kind
of knew what gardner minshew was
we know what kyler murray is and that
team you know washington so many new
parts
dwayne haskins his offseason
wasn't anointed the starter until late
in august all those things what's he
going to look like they're down 17
nothing overcoming that you hear about
dwayne haskins you know and the halftime
being a vocal leader i i guess i just
had the most questions about them or
what they were as a football team going
into this and they were the most
surprising i didn't expect jacksonville
to win but i knew what gardner minshew
was and i guess when i just looked at
washington i was totally clueless about
them and we saw defenses for real dwayne
haskins is growing as a player and
getting better
and they've got a decent stable of
running backs do you go um they could be
a real pain in the butt for teams and
they're just not going to be blown out
on a weekly basis they're going to hang
in there and annoy teams
we we disagree on all of them so far i
say arizona because i think arizona is
the best of the three teams
the toughest of the divisions they may
be the least likely to make the playoffs
because of where they are and they may
be the best of the three teams that
we've mentioned and i'm looking ahead at
the cardinals schedule they've got the
washington football team at home this
weekend then they have the lions at
carolina at the jets culminating in a
monday night game at dallas uh they
could be good
5-0 going into that cowboys game yes
they could you're right i mean there's
no there's no roster there that you look
at that you go oh well they're better
than the cardinals no
it's it's you know pretty even
throughout there this week will be fun
watching that front four or the five
first rounders of the football team
chasing around kyler murray that'll be
pretty cool and it'll be a challenge
certainly uh last week he did look at
that schedule chris look at that
schedule it is win as many games as you
can before the turn and then hold on to
your butts on the back yeah it's insane
on the back end i mean that really is
that's like murderer's row there's from
week six on uh they're gonna they're
gonna be the lesser team on the field in
just about every game other than the
dolphins and the giants to where i just
go hey on paper yeah i don't think the
cardinals are on the level with some of
those other teams we see on the on the
schedule
all right three members of the jets the
quarterback uh sam darnold the head
coach adam gase and running back le'veon
bell who was placed on injured reserve
yesterday and remember injured reserve
this year not as drastic as in past
years you can come back after three
weeks le'veon bell's got the hamstring
problem belle gas darnold which doesn't
belong and why uh and le'veon bell to me
i mean one first off he's hurt and not
playing you know two he's the one that i
look like i look at that just the most
underwhelming of the group
you know unless i know we can question
all of them like i get that but adam
gase a lot of his issues were set up by
prior people they were there that he had
nothing to do with
so okay there's that sam darnold he's a
little bit of a part of that
conversation too you know again lack of
offensive weapons the team hasn't been
built well they've had to reorganize
everything here and then of course
le'veon bell is part of why the team
isn't built well they've overpaid he
hasn't performed at all and honestly
he's the out of this group he's the only
headache off the field i mean he's he's
not like a jerk but he always seems to
stir the pot in some sort of way or his
name gets talked about like every other
week and uh i think that's why he
doesn't belong
well and i i look at it this way you
mentioned that adam gase is dealing with
issues that preceded his tenure the
le'veon bell is one that happened on his
watch but it wasn't his doing yeah
the former gm was determined to go get
this guy and overpay for him when gays
quite possibly was saying don't do it so
i agree with you
belt literally doesn't belong it's time
for them to move on from i think this
hamstring thing is the last nail and i
think he's going to get traded before
the tuesday after week 8. and if he
doesn't he should be it's going to be
best for everyone involved if that's
what they do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports